[Music]
shoutouts to the citizens of Jamelia for
providing all of these awesome questions
we got another one today from Alessandra
Sabrina mafias Pinilla I hope I said
that she must be Filipino right
yeah sure knit or Mexican good do they
have four first names like that well we
have the mom last name and then the bad
luck Wow combine it yeah hmm well she
asks has any of you guys ever
experienced unfair treatment between you
and your siblings what doesn't
if not are you just supposed to accept
it and how you know what it's a blessing
in disguise
are you the favor are you the favorite
what's going on oh I'm the favorite
that's why I'm not the favorite but I
tell myself I'm the favorite so that I
can [ __ ] cope with this you're the
middle right what do you think it's a
favor in your family so my mom
definitely loves my brother like that's
her mom's and brothers I mean moms in
their sons yeah she's different than
moms and daughters and I felt like my
dad really favored my little sister but
I put it in my own head that I'm both
their [ __ ] fears I feel like I'm the
more better one now the favorite but
before it wasn't cut out the worst grade
like your brother better yeah bad like
once now he's really cool I like it when
you have older younger brother older
brother younger sister right it sounds
middle so that my younger sister
obviously like she got everything she
wanted a little girl you know my older
brother had to do everything first so I
had secondhand things and like kind of
like my brother already did it and then
I have to do it too you know so it's
like all those different things so I
definitely got treated unfairly I feel
like sometimes my brother guy it's like
not stuff that's so bad but like my
brother gotta do things on the how come
I can't do that he's like he's older
he's this so I get it but I don't know
how to deal with it I'm still dealing
with it today so now it's because I'm
making more money than although I'm
pushing my highlight
yeah would be bad if they're watching I
had more freedoms than my sister so I
just made fun of her all the time
what is [ __ ]
the only boy in the family so I could go
out I could later I could go in the back
alley any sleepovers actually before the
home my sister couldn't go traveling and
I like what did you toss my friends one
time like alone that's a lot your sister
wanted speaker parties at your house and
other girls couldn't come she couldn't
go sleepover her friend's house or
anything yeah and she was older than me
she was two years older to me but I had
way more free time five my sister was
literally 1 million times more
responsible limine and she still wasn't
allowed to go like on a camping trip
with her friend what do you think that
is there like fear of getting pregnant
or laughs subjugating rate for me it's
like [ __ ] in general my parents
didn't want anyone [ __ ] at all you're
like my brother can get a girl pregnant
like my like why he allowed to do so but
then for me like what you're saying
I wouldn't like both out try to treat
equal if I do all right
let them do I would reserve the boy back
so like Steve I pull him back right cuz
then there's other guys that would do
harm to they go now his sister do
anything wrong some other guy doing
something stupid and his sister I'll be
back
huh don't pull me back plus you got
worse grades that's the thing my brother
had a C average like when he got to see
the family celebrated I got punished
we're getting a PD was dumb yeah true so
they're like oh you got a C breath I
will say he turned out to be pretty dumb
well the part of like oh you're a boy
you're gonna do good no matter what I
don't know I think as he played baseball
so he was an athlete or any played
football and so my dad was a baseball
player and so my dad would like coach
and then stuff and so I was like as long
as his athletics were really good like
everything was cool but his grades were
slipping a lot and then I was a
straight-a student so when I got a B I
got in trouble yeah what he's like I'm
as long as you're doing good at sports I
don't give a [ __ ] basically and like you
might only have to get good enough
grades to continue an athletic program
at a college right so I feel like in his
room I wasn't allowed to have any people
in my room ever even with the door open
the less
the less trouble you give the parents
though the more invisible you are but
the more they like you because you don't
give them any [ __ ] trouble but they
have to give more attention to the one
that's gonna be a handful you should
send like random mail that you Forge or
make about how bad your brother isn't
like getting in trouble so there's no
ham and then good ones about you you
know what I realize though is that my
sister was definitely my parents
favorite because they were trying to
protect her and not me it's a war
breaker right there what you should do
is just like you said fly out of the
radar save her money investment coin
make hella money dip out her freedom
lasting peace yeah I don't know how to
deal with it I [ __ ] I fought so hard
I think she did something wrong she
could be live or reside so get more
attention that way she's not I mean
maybe she is a bad kid and she and she
sees that wrong because I didn't see
everything properly I want my parents
are punishing me I was [ __ ] up so
that's why but in the moment I was like
why they're doing this to me you know I
feel like favorites do exist by the way
do you think that your dad cuz you're in
you that's for your now for sure for
sure right now now yeah it changes right
so that's one of the questions is
because it was a get better yeah I think
I think what it is is respect right so
like when he saw that when both of us
moved down we started our adult lives I
I paid for everything myself like I
didn't need any more help after after
you know a few years like once in a
while I come like borrow hundred dollars
I pay them back with interest
I like had all of these values that he
had I'm actually exactly like my dad so
he's he's like great I raised a I raised
a respectable daughter and so he'll
never say that to my face but I have to
put the words in in my head just like
you where I'm like he thinks very highly
of me now and you confirmed it anyway so
I'm pretty [ __ ] Italian he loves me
yeah but my brother he still needed a
lot of help so like he went to college
but then didn't get a job from anything
he studied and then like he was
struggling for a while he looked at home
after for a while like he he got his
girlfriend pregnant and then they got
married but luckily she was jailbait at
the time Brooks 18 he's 28 but luck
about nice we were in love and they made
the most adorable [ __ ] nephew I've
ever met in my life and he is worth it
my godson but they also shared the honor
with five other people so whatever so
they spread the wait he's definitely my
mom's favorite for no reason other than
him being here maybe he's just cuter
because he's alive that little year
there's no rationale yeah she didn't
like how much attention I needed
whenever I want to do a PowerPoint
presentation to your mom about why you
should be the favorite and not not it
was like no I want to do I want her mom
to love her like we like what if you
were just a mean kid mean is that like a
crybaby like my brother would say things
like was so what you can't even boy well
what I think girls become more
independent quicker yeah so they're
awesome they're awesome - I feel like it
also could because maybe your mom
couldn't have a lot of like guy friends
so that's what who like is her guy the
guy friend yeah cry-baby but your
toughest [ __ ] nails know what it was
was like exactly my brother would say
things like you know what you're like
what do you want to view in Europe he'd
say things like I want to be a pitcher
you say that he wanted to help people
and my mom was always like oh my god he
was a help he's a boy what do you want
to be because I feel like I want to be
an astronaut because I wanted to do do
cool things on the moon and then I found
out we could suffocate if you take your
helmet off then I wanted to be an actor
and she was like oh no and so she
thought like oh she was would an actor
who she wants to be famous but really I
just wanted to share stories but anyway
my brother didn't become a policeman but
she still has this thing in her head
like oh he wants to all he wants to do
is help people what if it it is like
your brother loves to baby and take care
and you didn't she didn't you didn't let
her
do that because you became independent
too fast and then your brother should
get to coddle she gets to still purpose
you should have babied more no my
brother was awesome but he was a little
[ __ ] about it like you Nelson he would
be like look at what I get to do and I
just had sex with this girl in my room
last night you even noticed and at least
you weren't [ __ ] doctor you can rp1
I'm knocking now everybody my brother my
dick I feel like this sibling rivalry
though it just doesn't change no matter
what like the [ __ ] that I hear from my
cousins my mom and I'm like dude y'all
are I thought you would be over by now
it's like you're pulling it into me my
brother you don't have agent [ __ ] never
brother were [ __ ] tight as [ __ ] dude
my brother will tell you my brother Tate
Tuesday that I had some special
treatment growing up yeah we try to sit
him down and actually try to have him
provide an argument for what my special
treatment was he couldn't do it he's
like uh well one time are you laundry
for a week and I had to do it I'm like
okay just feels like your parents love
you more that's the only extroverted
person in my family so I just get more
attention that's all yeah yeah I think
that's a common problem when you
internalize your issues and your problem
that you're having a moment so that one
time when he had to do the laundry right
he didn't like boys now anything he's
like I'm [ __ ] doing the laundry Steve
even do it last week all right and then
like 20 years later seems like what
happened and he's like you you didn't do
the laundry that one time [ __ ] days
bro is eternal I internalized because
I'm five years older than my brother and
so I was the guinea pig for a lot of
things and because I was like straight-a
student didn't do drugs didn't party I
didn't even have friends to go out with
like I was such a good like like
homebody
person but I got grounded for two weeks
for not making my bed because they were
just like well we need to ground her for
something and then my brother
spoken up left and right by the time he
was that age and he
got the same punishment for drinking
alcohol on campus the same exact
punishment and I'll never let it go
I had turtle eyes the [ __ ] out of that
I'll bring it up to your pants huh oh
yeah all the time
okay just to further roaster brother my
favorite thing about it he always tries
to be her dad the same hat he tries to
drive the same kind of car he always
drives the same truck or doesn't like
trucks that much but he's just trying to
win the approval by that yes and so he's
just trying to emulate him he literally
had a kid with uh he had a kid early
like your dad did so it's what the
funniest thing is is Nikki doesn't even
try and she's exactly like her old man I
didn't want to be like I know and you
don't even [ __ ] try it's just like
you guys are talking it's it's funny
here you guys talk about the same thing
the same way we're saying it this thing
like yeah yeah yeah and he's like
adjusting his hat can't but nobody's
paying attention oh I love my brother
though we have a good relationship it's
just that it's true I was like you're
the favorite and I have to win also he's
my in-law gotta roses us we can